Je vous en parle enfin après des mois d'écriture
de dessin par Paka
de colorisation, d'impression de distribution... tout ce que vous voulez
Le tome 2 de ma bande dessinée "Roger et ses humains"
est enfin disponible partout !
dans votre librairie, votre Fnac, Cultura, votre kebab
votre boulangerie, tout ce que vous voulez, j'en suis très fier
Et vous pouvez cliquer sur le lien dans la description
si vous voulez le commander en ligne, c'est possible également.
Et aussi, sans le dire à personne,
je travaille sur un projet qui me tient énormément à coeur.
Vous avez vu le titre de la vidéo, c'est un petit peu la suite logique après la BD
qui me faisait vraiment rêver :
Je prépare un dessin animé "Roger et ses humains"
voilà c'est vraiment incroyable de bosser là dessus
de faire les textes, travailler avec l'animation, faire des voix
et vous aurez un petit extrait à la fin de la vidéo.
Mais je le sais que vous avez plein de questions
et moi j'ai plein de réponses,
alors c'est parti, conférence de presse !
*musique*
Bonjour à tous
Merci d'être là
prenez place, qui veut commencer ?
- Ouais !
- Oui ?
- Vous voulez commencer ?
- Non, allez-y
OK. Arthur pour le " journal de l'approximation".
C'est quoi "Robert et ses amis", exactement ?
Alors "Roger et ses Humains" c'est une BD que j'ai écrite et qui est dessinée par Paka
Le tome 1 est sorti il y a 3 ans et j'en suis très fier
puisque c'était un paris de faire une BD avec des nouveaux personnages
Et pas de faire une BD "Cyprien"
Et puis les gens ont été au rendez-vous
et le tome 2 vient de sortir aujourd'hui, je suis très content
"Romuald et son robot", tome 7, sortie bientôt
Oui ?
Corentin, "Comparateur Revue"
C'est quoi la différence le tome 1 ?
C'est la suite directe
Avec un nouveau méchant, une nouvelle histoire,
des nouvelles situations, des nouveaux strips, Paka a amélioré les dessins
Il y a plus de situations, il y a plus d'aventures
et il y a plus d'émotions, bref c'est tout en mieux quoi !
Bon, ok, vous m'avez convaincu d'acheter la BD, je vous l'achète tout de suite.
Merci.
Bonne lecture. Oui ?
Bonjour, Dorothée, Dessin Animé Magazine
vous avez parlé d'un dessin animé, vous pouvez nous en dire plus ?
Oui, je suis super content de bosser sur un dessin animé "Roger et ses humains"
ça reprend  les textes et les personnages
- D'accord...
- C'est drôle !
Et vous faites quoi sur le dessin animé ?
J'ai écrit les textes et je fais la voix de Roger le robot
est-ce que on pourrais le comparer au dessin animé titeuf?
NON!
non? d'accord...
non mais on pourrat le comparer a je sait pas moi...les casos
ou un gars une fille? enfin c'est format court quoi
et bah VOILA une comparaison,super!
*voix de robot*Bonjour!Roger pour "Roger et ses humains"quand sortira le dessin animé ?
alors pour l'instant je peux juste vous dire qu'on bosse dessus
y a pas encore de date de diffusion, dès qu'il y en aura une je vous la dirait
j’espère que ça vous vas comme réponse
non!
sypa l'ambiance
sorry!je suis désolée I am so late
Rachel "retard mag' "
heuuu, c'est quoi la différence entre le tome 1 et le tome 2 ?
Quelqu'un 'a déjà posé la question en fait...
ha fuck c'est parce que je suis toujour en retard
approximativement il a fait l'animation mais pas les voix
thank you so much merci
no-non rien a voir c'est pas du tout ça
Patrick pour les "cahiers de la précision"
y aura t-il des dédicaces?Si oui ou et quand ?Précisément?
et bah, oui tout a fait on a prévu des dédicaces un petit peu partout en France
Il va y en avoir à Paris, à Bordeaux,à Toulouse, à La Rochelle
ouais,est ce que vous pouvez être un peu plus précis sur le lieux et la date des dédicaces?Par exemple a la minute près?
Non non mais si vous me suivez sur Twitter ou sur Instagram
vous aurez toutes les infos sur le lieu,la date...vous inquiétez pas vous serez tenus au courant
*gémissement bizarre* pas très très précis
est ce que vous pouvez nous parler du dessin animé?
et bah j'en ai déjà parlé tout a l'heure en fait...
*gémissement de colère* je était sure j'en était sure
moi moi, moi moi,ici ici, moi moi
oui
YES!heuuuu...Bonjour!Rozales rapide magasine
oui je me rappelle très bien de vous...
*rire nerveux*super ca fait plaisir
on peut lui amener un verre d'eau s'il vous plait ?
*bruit d'eau*
il est sérieux lui?
ça a pris combien de temps a faire Roger...tome deux et ses humains
alors ça a pris six mois d'écriture,a faire le tome deux..
et heuuu pareil pour les dessins parce que en fait paka a dessiné les planches
en même temps que je finissait de les écrire
vous pouvez pas aller plus vite?
donc en fait j'ai écrit ça en parallèle de la préparation de mon court-métrage
Lunaire ou dessine moi un alien ou l'épopée temporelle
mais j'avais la trame depuis deux ans
Terminé c'est super j'ai adoré la fin j'ai hâte de lire le tome 3
il lis vite hein ?
j'ai entendu parler d'un  coffret j'imagine que quelqu'un a déjà posé la question
et bah non non pas encore
c'est vrai ?ho ben est-ce que vous pouvez nous parler du...
parlez nous du coffret!
chut!!
bien sur si vous n'avez pas lu le premier tome
il existe un coffret qui comprend les des tomes
ainsi qu'un paper-toy a construire soi-même
et sur Amazon il y a une couverture spéciale du premier tome
ainsi qu'une photo dédicacée par paka et moi-même dans 100 coffrets au hasard
merci
et sauf si il y a d'autres questions mais je peut vous proposer  de regarder un extrait du dessin animé Roger et ses humains maintenant
oh yes!
good idea!
ho oui!
je vais le regarder de manière très précise!
moi j'en ai vu plein des dessins animes
c'est bon tout le monde est prêt ?
ça commence quand ?
*indéchiffrable*
bon un peu de silence quand même
regardez regar...
on voulais juste...enfin on...
sinon moi j'annule y a pas de soucis
*blanc*
d'accord
*(re)blanc*
voila
vous allez voir j'adore la musique qu generique...j'adore
*musique de générique*
*bruits de couteaux*
et donc Roger tu sert a quoi exactement?
et toi hugo/ugo tu sert a quoi exactement ?
Putain t'es obligé d’être aussi désagréable?
hé,tu sait faire a manger?
non mais je peux apprendre
QUOI???
tu veux dire que j'auraisplus jamais a faire la cuisine?
*cri de joie très aigu*
a moi la liberté!
c'est la fin du patriarcat
*rires*
mais non me regarde pas comme ça c'est normal c'est la pression de la société
roger
voila,avec une recette trouvée sur internet j'ai préparé un gâteau pour ton anniversaire
bruits de nouriture
non mais attend il est super bon!
le plus dur etait de trouver les  feuilles de canabis
ton visage il tourne
je kiffe trop ce robot !
c'est doux la table
vous voulez pas on se caresse tous les genoux?
roger
*gemmissements non-identifiés*
désolé pour le gâteau tout a l'heure,j'ai fait une omelette pour me faire pardonner
ho pff y a pas de cannabis j’espère ?
non
cool j'ai trop la dalle !
*bruits de nourriture*
et j'ai trouvé moi même les champignons
hm? les champignons ?
je kiffe trop ce robot
franchement j'ai envie de vous lecher l'oreille a tous
mais comme un copain pas comme un amoureux tu vois?
plus on fait du camping, on fait du poney
qui fait l'poney?
celui qui a le plus de cheveux, ce sera pas Roger
heureux qu mon plat vous plaise
je vais en donner aux enfants du quartier
*applaudissements*
ha moi j'adore
amazing
*je n'ai pas compris*
merci c'est très gentil
Cyprien!Cyprien!Cyprien!Cyprien!
et voila le tome 2 de Roger et ses humains est enfin disponible absolument partout
vous pouvez cliquer sur le lien dans la description pour le commander
et moi je suis très très fier de cette bande dessinée,j'ai adoré l'ecrire je me suis attaché aux personnages
et je suis vraimment très très content de ça donc j'espere que ca va vous plaire
n’hésitez pas a me suivre sur les réseaux sociaux pour avoir un peu plus d'informations notamment sur les dédicaces
et moi je vous dit a très vite